top of the morning top of the morning
top of the morning top of the morning
that's like kendrick with that new hot
dog
actually barely got to hear it
you know what's funny so kendrick lamar
just came out with this track
that's meaning out where he goes top of
the morning top of the morning
everyone's like what is with kendrick
he's off on some weird [ __ ]
and so he made a collab with this dude
baby keem who i found out it's his
cousin
so this guy baby keem is popping off
yeah but here's where the funny part is
baby keem tweeted at keemstar recently
being like hey another keem
and then everyone was like yo this is
not it
that's the funny didn't he then just
tweet no
yeah
hey keemstar well maybe
if maybe if kim's ever read a book
it was used in a book oh he doesn't know
what a book is
welcome everybody to h3 after dark
you know what it is
it's number 50. oh
wow that's pretty significant
thank you dan i was getting there
hbo max upstart kraken and hello fresh
hi i am ethan
the podcast h3 after dark that's marvel
made a trailer
to promote our podcast
well guys we have a fantastic show here
today
um
and uh we're just so excited to be here
on this beautiful friday afternoon
and
i'm wearing pink but it's not a gender
reveal
not yet next week we're doing a general
oh
oh gabe are you getting a new car
i'm shopping for a new clock
[Music]
you would stop for a better uh
5g connection
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] so what kind of
well that's that's very exciting um
are you close to getting a new car there
you talk to the people you know
[ __ ]
baby yeah
hey it's friday what does that mean
halloween horror nights baby
oh oh horror night let's go oh okay are
we at horror night already oh yeah it's
that time of year getting there
yeah baby tonight [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
[ __ ]
all right oh some lady's coming behind
you is that the sales lady
oh no she's just going in the store oh
you're right outside the store okay
can we watch you buy a car can we follow
the journey
go in go go shop at the car oh wow it
sounds so clear all of a sudden yeah why
is
this
why is your body so loud and you're it's
like a weird life
also looks like his glasses are like
like a filter
don't they
put a mask on you go ahead
all right maybe
maybe call back when you guys are
signing the paperwork and we can
congratulate you
how's that sound yeah okay
we're calling here guys take care good
luck good luck with the car happy for
you [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
cameos behind the game man seriously and
you can find him on cameo there's really
been a degradation in the audio quality
of his calls
i feel like it's progressive too
though everyone around him it works
that's possible we had him prank too and
he was just
gabe doesn't work the dude behind the
camera works
that's part of the magic it doesn't make
any sense
yeah you you know what he's saying
so
don't miss too much
so a little bit of an update for you
guys
the new show that we're going to air
this sunday
is
being
delayed
[Music]
we're delaying it to sunday of next week
because
i think we were we were let's be honest
we were
biting off a little more than we could
chew
in terms of a timeline there's so much
work to do with creating the set and the
graphics and everything and
you know
pinning down the concepts so we were
late last night on
on wednesday night we wrapped up a
really late night of shooting for off
the rails
and uh we we made the decision that it
should wait until next week i'm sorry
guys i see lots of uh let's see lots of
anger
[Laughter]
we just weren't ready guys i'm sorry
also we want to make sure that our first
app is beautiful and perfect as possible
so next sunday will for sure be
the launch date with peace and love
peace and love please don't throw
tomatoes at me in the chat i can't
handle that kind of abuse i'm ex i'm
vulnerable
we're doing our best
wouldn't you guys prefer that it was
like launched properly
that it was perfect that it flowed
beautifully you're asking the chat yeah
i think you will usually want to ask
that question people go yeah i want to
be perfect but i'm getting feeling these
guys are like no i want anything now
you know
with peace and love of course
of course
so i'm sorry about that guys but i
promise next week
so is the sound okay because like half
of the chat is saying something is
i when i talked about the sponsors
earlier i didn't have my mic open
because i was just trying to let you
know and then and now i think it's
snowballed into uh
i couldn't speak okay but it's a thing
yeah
everyone and everyone is audible and
it's wonderful okay excellent so let's
move on we got so much great stuff
obviously we need uh we got a doggy bed
situation
oh poor elf
bed
there's two beds and shredders on both
of them i know fredo is trying to get
one
or that's my bad that's so like shredder
too he's like what do you want from me i
get both bets
all right now the show can begin you
know what theodore said to alfredo when
he ate his poop all right
i know it was you
[Laughter]
i know
you broke my heart
oh it's too early
really i look we celebrated
[Music]
i've been nothing but good and loyal to
you and how do you repay me by eating
about my [ __ ]
it's another meatball alfredo it's a
[ __ ]
i know it was you freedom i mean for
[ __ ] sake dog that even for you that's
disgusting
i cry
i so cry i feel so vulnerable uh i feel
so violated i cry
i medicate a tear
i make it a tear because you you heard
of me so bad alfredo
anyway and you know you waited my [ __ ]
and you go back for seconds
that went from like don corleone to the
mario brothers
[Laughter]
[Music]
a piece of [ __ ] out of your mouth
a human feet turn
[Music]
by the way yeah we're not letting him
like our faces still no we're not ready
we're not ready yet alfredo what is it
doing
so you know what we had a great episode
yesterday about cav cav in our lawsuit
ela yeah
it was a lot of fun and just for peace
and love
this was totally unplanned i just was
having fun i said when you think of ryan
kavanagh
what comes to mind
you know
what
one possibility is like um
c ceo entrepreneur
uh what
it's the jeff bezos song born in 1984.
yeah it could be a media mogul
movie producer
right the man who kissed harvey
weinstein on the head right yeah i mean
the owner of trailer
so let's see what people said
this is the first time for me meeting
ryan cavanaugh
that's a hot meme
this is the first time before me in the
marvel universe that was unexpected and
i definitely tipped the hat to jenna for
that one
[Music]
uh this is a a picture of him kissing
harvey weinstein of course and then well
this is a good because someone said wait
which one is i actually
wait is this him or is this him
i'll never figure it out
do you see it you know what i saw
something i'm going to regret bringing
this up but go ahead here i'll um
you can keep going i'll i'll pull it up
in a second wait ryan kavanagh this is
him right see
i think that's harvey wines
yeah you're learning but they are very
similar looking
oh no i think this is him
okay now i'm confused
that's him but flipped
i love that
uh it rhymes with donzi
um i don't get it
oh ponzi oh i didn't get it you see he
was actually his ex-partner accused him
of running a ponzi scheme um in open
court it was reported there was a report
in variety magazine about it okay but
wait what did you pull up dan oh this is
a hot meme from the subreddit yeah so
someone says do you see it now down now
this is of course dan says he doesn't
think ryan looks like harvey and and
like this person has assembled a very
well crafted side by side
it's really hard to deny
well what does dan think yeah i mean
you're well i mean i feel like yeah they
were they were pretty strategic with
these pictures very picked to um to you
know draw parallels between the two
and you know there's a vegas the vaguest
resemblance bro are you on but but i
would never
i would never confuse these two men
dan's on kevin on payroll
[Music]
uh ryan kavanagh what wait is this
edited when you type in ryan cavanaugh
it shows harvey weinstein
i mean that that's confusing
i believe it's an edit it is an edit
okay see i wasn't sure yeah go ahead and
type it let's see i mean
that's so confusing
oh schedule oh dude i didn't even talk
about this
[ __ ] trailer fight club is having
donald trump
give full live in person commentary oh
my god
really
is that reek of desperation or what on 9
11 yeah 9 11.
this guy is out of his mind right
what
donald trump is going to be live
commentary on a bunch of old ass retired
fights this is apparently the most
anticipated fight of the year these guys
haven't boxed in like 30 plus years and
this is the most anticipated fight ethan
okay sorry trump i know ethan please
stand up this will be the best show the
best boxing match of all time and this
is this is a testament to just how
shitty trailer is is they had like a
press conference about it um yesterday
wait let me say let me say guess how
many views it had on youtube
and i had donald trump saying he wanted
to fight biden
they go who would you want to bomb he
was why don't we pull up the clip oh no
they're going to sue yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know
biden uh he's very sleepy he's very old
i would knock him out uh very fast very
fast extremely fast it'd be over very
fast it was just a dumb gag honestly but
guess how many views that had
former president
hyping up this fight
youtube
100
you ruined the game
three thousand
three thousand three thousand views he
blew it
nice i bet that was worth it yeah
and moreover i went and looked i like i
googled around i looked on twitter to
see if like there was any chatter about
it because that seems like something
that people would be flipping out about
of like trump challenges tied into a
boxing match and like nobody gives a
[ __ ] because it was just a stupid gag it
was so dumb
guess what
yeah but i have a feeling that
what oh he wants to he wants to fish the
economy
benefits everybody
no
is that biden justifying a fight with
trump across the economy
guess what
across the economy
that's what i say when i buy cigarettes
and take one and throw 19 out
i go i go
guess what
it grows
does it really does buying a pack of
cigarettes or throwing out really help
anyone but some sick [ __ ] executives
probably not nobody yeah
that might not be true
yeah so if this is if this fight's a
disaster which i'm sure it will be
um this might be it i mean this might be
full on bankruptcy
i don't know how they keep floating this
[ __ ]
yeah
and he he was hoping that i would fund
this event basically right quest
like [ __ ] ethan didn't pay us i don't
know how we're gonna pay these guys
up next hmm i tried looking him up he
looks familiar but i can't put my finger
on this is the exact same screenshot we
already saw
but not with a quote tweet
we do a little trolling it's called we
do a little trolling
[ __ ] goon can you believe it
yeah rumor has it trump's about to um
announce his his candidacy
we like to troll
so that's exciting maybe we'll announce
it at the trailer fight
you bad boy tom
uh this is something really important we
need to talk about
dan i don't know what the [ __ ] this is
to be honest with you dan you got to
make up your mind because people are
getting mad at me like i'm supposed to
buy dan the sixteen thousand dollar
command chair right and he keeps
changing his mind lastly he wanted the
gatling gun yeah so we went to go buy
the gatling gun if you recall yeah and
the company that sells it only accepts
payment via paypal and we were like this
yeah yeah put it on a credit card so
like yeah if something's weird exactly
disputed yeah so that was kind of where
about 16 000 yeah that sounds good but
no what this is is um
they are this is an auction
starting at one dollar they open in 15
days for all of the vehicles from mad
max fury road okay what what are you
saying i want you
to bid on a morton joe's [ __ ] throne
car and that can be my two chair on the
pod which one which one is that one
right there the giggle horse okay you're
making jokes i want to actually buy you
a chair i'm not obviously the bid is at
one dollar i'm not gonna put you how
about up to the amount that you were
willing to pay for the chair we can
[ __ ]
how is this a chair
we i
will do anything we have to to make it
happen how sick would that be all right
all right look at that thing
are you a fan of movies wait i love the
movie
it could act as a double double because
dan needs a new chair and someone needs
a new car
so right you're getting two for one here
yeah it's a little twofer that is true
or a car
i'm sure that's road safe
so wait where do you sit i don't see a
throne uh
look there's like a whole thing on the
back
we can also listen it doesn't have to be
that one there there's lots of other
cars well at least give me one a good
one that we can actually buy and i'll
bid on it but we could get the war rig
you know like the giant truck that they
drive that's on there there are no bids
on this lot it's not open yet oh okay we
can also hang it from the ceiling like
the smithsonian how about this one dan
why don't we just get this one yeah why
not open the roof you're right oh no
that and zach could play guitar on the
phone
he's got the stack of amps that's the
one he's selling this [ __ ] yeah because
what else are they i mean it's probably
been sitting there for years what else
are you gonna do with it okay so now
it's a three combo we have three uses
for one we should all send it like a
megazord
and do this yes this could just be the
whole control room exactly
oh that's kind of interesting actually
the whole control room
how sick would that be look at that then
you can i could play musical i wonder
how does it have the dimensions let's
see because the roof is pretty tall in
here it is very tough let's see it says
uh
um
it's
repurposed 8x8 man missile carrier
literally it's called the biggest car
ever
a dual wagon where do you see that
i think that's the doof warrior
yeah coma the doof warrior
yeah that was the guy that was
uh playing the guitar that shoots flames
out of it
um [ __ ] sick dude
wait it's in australia dan you really
want oh my god you want me to bang this
and ship it from australia you psychotic
oh my god how much would that cost is
that a problem
yeah it might be a problem
uh
yeah i'm down a bit a dollar sure
can i get the elvis
it's the second row third one that's
pretty we can ship that right that one's
reasonable this one's very reasonable
i mean yeah we could we could get you up
on that gatling gun for sure guess what
that will grow
yeah yeah of australia
benefits everybody right
hurts no yeah i'm not trying to grow the
australian economy
all right because this is america
just just promise me you you'll think
about it just can we get more options
i think there was there was at least
like 10 more options on that step
responsibility and get a [ __ ] chair
bro i you i get the original we both
well i guess we could just go back to
that one i mean it was should i really
what do you guys think that was the one
that was 16 grand and i i felt like that
was probably too much to spend on the
game
but the gatling gun one seemed like a
good compromise because it was like five
grand or something but then the company
seemed a little bit do you guys think
it's shady to send someone seven grand
on paypal for for like a share that may
or may not exist
yeah
yeah
and then like why can't i pay you a
credit card it's just odd
right what else would you call that jaw
rule well jar what do you think should i
do it that's right okay okay okay i
would call that a fraud
well you got to find something else
because i don't want to get any more
[ __ ] and the same goes for you zach
people giving me [ __ ] about the
billboard it was on you zach i told zach
i was gonna buy him a mayo billboard and
it was on you guys to tell me where and
where what to buy it i'm not gonna go
[ __ ] talk here's the thing the
original i still think we need one of
these
that's that's kind of the one dan was
was looking at
let me send yeah here also send it up so
either found something for dan
oh the tank yeah i mean isn't that what
you were looking at it wasn't this exact
one um this is a decent option though
this is this one actually moves wrong
with you
this one actually moves actually you got
a good point isn't this a mobility
vehicle yeah
okay so why so
that's kind of epic that is epic
excuse me sir has got a really good
point here
this is dan is going to be uh
mobility tank mary
because the the one with the gatling
guns had like tank treads but it's all
it's just for show it doesn't actually
roll around but this okay let's look
into this swerving sword love over here
that's the [ __ ] out of me if i saw one
of those
on the [ __ ] street we could do gags
with the gatsby is that street legal i
mean that looks like they're up the road
this is epic
what is this for like imagine if i was
sitting on that at my office
here
hila wants it
[ __ ] it for me
but you know it's like
what are they doing sending in is there
like a platoon of like uh
of a paraplegics uh going to the front
line of uh
iraqis according to their website they
they depict a person using it um on a
farm and i actually could see that like
if you needed a mobility chair but you
you work on like
on out in fields and stuff why is it
snipers
i love the one that looks like a
completely regular office chair
and which one is that the one you were
looking at before which one looks like
an office chair like that
in the middle oh in the middle
this this this no this this there oh oh
right yeah it's like a total normal
yeah
i feel like that's a home project
dan you should get that and roll around
the office like dr evil yeah
he's going to tear up our foundation
here adult full size
i'm looking it up right now
you already have a gatsby what do you
need that for
okay you already have a friend so it's
more expensive than the than the tank
chair but it's less expensive than the
original zero gravity chair
but you're not getting a better use and
look it retails at 15 000 but our price
is only 12.
you can resell it
on camera you're not even gonna see the
tracks you're just gonna be in a normal
chair
well we camo it up and
you know some guns and stuff you're
vetoing really
well dude wow it's kind of lucky [ __ ]
toad
bro
let's not forget where we came from that
giant thing
well did you i don't know if you were
here but dan did the measurements of the
original one and it would take up like
basically three-fourths the whole space
of where a b
olivia and myself is it would just be
all of that
that's huge [ __ ] funny
we need like a camera on the roof
looking down on you
oh i was thinking i would mount it onto
the chair itself so like as i'm spinning
you know right and maybe what we could
set up is a fog machine so every time
you move it it spits out fog
smoke oh yeah
absolutely yeah
i'm gonna do it like noise when it opens
up like futuristic music
the year is 2021
but the future is now damn it's just
said throne i've been the greatest game
engaged ever made what are you doing
here
the year one more option it's 2021 and
alfredo should say theodore's [ __ ]
here dan he left not good it's only 179
bucks
[Music]
that's a good chair for uh for cav cav
oh because it's flipped indeed
[Laughter]
true
hello
all right we're working through top of
the show stuff here this came from the
subreddit uh they said hey i was just at
law school in the library doing a little
research short and but sweet
i don't know if you've seen this either
i have
one got a legal book i couldn't believe
it actually you better believe it what's
that what
wait damn it i tried to pause
[Music]
flip open the book
[Applause]
and that is matt hussein zada
vs ethan klein and eloquent defendants
and guess what ryan's about to get his
chapter two
the sequel
sequel
what is this book is that something we
can do it's like yeah for sure it's just
case law study like you go to like
copyright if you're researching
copyright and you're trying to like
research case law which is like uh
important presidential cases you read
about them and the rulings and it's like
oh hussein zara versus klein
i want to buy it
we should buy it
should send mata copy right
that would be polite yeah yeah just you
know
oh i don't know this is someone got mad
at me doing a performative activism
is that just your caption there dan what
am i supposed to do with this yeah it is
just my caption okay
um
i'm not in on this because i didn't grow
up here but you watched a lot of blues
clues growing up
did you
um
yeah i watched blue's clothes
really
[Laughter]
because you know you were like 10 or 11
years old when it premiered so you know
it's made for like three-year-olds it
was on tv i watched it all the time this
is nick jr it's like for like little
little kids
dude
there's no way in hell that way
anyone here watch it
oh it was a huge fan i watched it but
because i had a younger it was on the tv
all the [ __ ] time and you were just
chilling watching blue's clues i would
put on nickelodeon because i was looking
for cartoons and i would or when i was
home from like sick i would see blue
clues all the [ __ ] time i've watched
many episodes of blue clues
did you cry during that video
no i didn't cry i i was called like a
[ __ ] zack you're always crying
right i am i'm emotional
for christ's sake
but that oh i see what's going on dan
you're trying to call me out yeah
i don't think you were actually watching
i was touched by the message you got a
[ __ ] problem with that bro
like what the [ __ ] i think that's
defamation
kudos to nick jr for that marketing
though hit wrapping in the older crowd
you know
go ahead
no i've set my pace you didn't you
weren't touched by this message no and
i'm younger than you and it was way i
was waiting for you dad i'm like two
years younger than you
oh you are yeah
i thought it was very sweet i don't know
what to tell you i thought it was
[ __ ] sweet it was it was very sweet
what is this this is dan right now
[Music]
exactly thank you zach
hi 40 million views god i wonder why
nobody cares about this video nobody was
touched by this video dan
ethan's the only one lying about like
performing this activism
you got a second
okay you remember how when we were
younger we used to um
run around and hang out with blue and
find clues and talk to mr salt freak out
about the map i remember all that [ __ ]
dan one
[Laughter]
day i was like oh hey guess what big
news i'm leaving uh this is my brother
joe he's your new best friend
wendy remembers and she's older than i
am
what do you have to say about that
i think you and steve here are about the
same age
he's older than me google that yeah
he's got to be like have 20 on me
he didn't see each other he's 47.
can we just this guy yeah why do you
think he looks good he looks younger no
he's healthy he's healthy
i think it's more about a statement of
how i look than him
not by you
everyone's against me today
i always have this fear of like i'm
really i look up to people who age well
i think it's so cool
so
i wasn't thinking about you mm-hmm
i'm just surprised
we've
massacred this video
let's just we have to watch it without
saying anything i'm just gonna stare at
you angrily
you got a second
okay you remember how when we were
younger we used to
run around and hang out with blue and
find clues and talk to mr salt freak out
about the mail and do all the fun stuff
and then one day i was like oh hey guess
what big news i'm leaving uh this is my
brother joe he's your new best friend
and then i got on a bus and i left
and we didn't see each other for like a
really long time
can we just talk about that
great because i i realized that that
that was kind of abrupt let the
conversation i just kind of went to
college
and
that was really
challenging by the way but great
because i got to use my mind and take a
step at a time and now i literally am
doing many of the things
that i wanted to do
and then look at you and look at all you
have done and all you have a comment are
you staring at that time
i started watching this in public and i
had to turn it off because i started
and now it's what
student loans and um
jobs
and families and some of it
has been kind of hard
you know
i know you know
and i wanted to tell you that i i really
couldn't have done all of that
without your help
[Music]
and in fact
all the help that you helped me with
when we were younger is still helping me
today
right now
and that's super cool
i guess i just wanted to say
that after all these years
i never forgot you
ever
and i'm super glad
[Laughter]
can i defend you ethan you know how you
know ethan's sincere he played the whole
thing without stopping right which is
the first time i've ever seen that true
the history okay that's a fair
counterpart it's weird
i do have some more evidence though if
you take a look at my screen but anyway
you know like so this blues clues was
like a huge cultural phenomenon yeah i
never watched it so i kind of read about
what happened it was he had to leave the
show he just bailed and uh
i guess left a lot of open questions for
people like olivia who's are you feeling
okay are you doing all right it feels
good to know he never forgot me i don't
know it was very sweet it was well
delivered it was beautiful
um
you gotta issue dan use anything
steve has a follow-up comment
weird to watch me at age ten
ten as a child bro it's not that [ __ ]
weird you're literally bullying a
ten-year-old do you understand what's
wrong with you you're bowling that's and
you're right i have to i have to side
with ethan on this one like what are you
talking about what is what exactly do
you expect
to be doing for
i watched it when i was like 10 11. yeah
how dare you
you lose clues is designed for children
age 3 to 5.
so what design yeah lots of stuff you
know
okay you never saw r-rated movie dan
before you were the age of seventeen
yeah
movies were designed for seven teams it
was scary it was just yeah yeah yeah
just a couple minutes ago
you were dying to get this
the doof
mission
yeah right the doof car yeah go ahead
preach
that's all i gotta say oh i thought it's
going somewhere
i think she's implying maybe that i'm
hurting my chances of that
no i thought she's in front of that
you're you're a fan going over you're
fanboying over this doof car yeah
there's a little bit of a there's a
little bit of a maturity difference
between the mad max movie if you lose
a product that was not intended for your
exact age for example an r-rated movie
under the age of 17. no like i said
never okay those are scary let me ask
you this scary have you ever played a
video game that was rated all ages
uh like a mario game or something yes
yeah i suppose you [ __ ] did okay
fancy free that's a good move that's a
good move okay i gotta give you props
for that what was your first rate in our
movie dude
i don't know i hope they're throwing
tomatoes to dan and not me they are they
are they are and that's okay i invite
your tomatoes
thank you for challenging me that was
fun but i mean come on what's wrong with
what's in blue's clue no i mean i just
thought it was funny it wasn't like my
primary show but like i've watched many
episodes of it
okay
you don't blame me dude
give me do trivia do blues clues trivia
i mean i don't know any because i didn't
watch blue's clues because it was i was
too old for it google blues choose
trivia what the [ __ ] well olivia knows
everything olivia quizzing it's
something that only a true fan would
know
well i pulled up
i'm not a true fan
oh
okay i got one for you what was the name
of steve's notebook
notebook yeah what was it called what do
you call it it's called notebook no okay
it's simple
what's happening
nothing don't worry about that
um
do you want me to read this comment what
was the name of the notebook zach handy
dandy no oh handy dandy yeah go ahead
ethan how is your weight loss journey
going have you considered going on a
calorie deficit diet i saw a very
in-depth reddit post and then she
celebrated that a user
um created laying out some super helpful
advice for you he lost 70 pounds
yeah they donated 50 dollars thank you
so much
i'm gonna use that money to bolster
or i would say undo my deficit no i'm
kidding uh good i mean it's only been
three days but you actually did start
yeah that post kind of
i downloaded my fitness app
you guys are gonna laugh at me because
yesterday i had
let's see you guys are gonna you guys
are gonna make fun of me everyone's
gonna say i'm [ __ ] up now
but yeah yesterday i had 1240 calories
and people can be like ethan you can't
lose weight that way it's not healthy i
was like yeah i had a headache and i was
starving but that's the way it is
no but that's not true because the day
before i had 2400 calories which is
about where my equilibrium is so that
was a bad day how much which one
i think 2 300
is maintaining weight got it so the day
before i had 2400
the day before that i had 1 800 which is
a deficit
so i've had you know one decent deficit
one equilibrium day and one very strong
deficit day
and today
um
actually we had an egg sandwich let me
add that
what'd we say 400 calories i just wanted
i thought it was cold that that post
actually did um
push you to do it that's part of why i
wanted it so that the guy knows i'm in
yeah the guy actually inspired me i have
to say
well maybe pull up the pulse give it to
me
just to show you guys but yeah and you
know look for it he said he's doing
something similar he was on like 1500 to
1800 calories a day
and at that you can lose like two pounds
a week and i i feel like i just need to
see some results i know it's not like
people just go run you fat [ __ ] when you
just go run you fat [ __ ] when you just
walk around
well the problem is that if you do it
unrealistically you won't actually be
able to
maintain listen people say people say
just stop eating
and then when you stop eating they go
that's not the healthy way to do it why
don't you just run
it's like yeah i gotta i can't lose
weight on my own
on my own terms
lose weight your fat [ __ ]
but on my terms i think this is it
i think i found you got it okay
here to this hooper trooper that lost uh
70 pounds in five months that's what the
[ __ ] is up bro
because if i could lose 50 pounds i'd be
like
i'd be right there where i want to be
okay let's check his progress from 265
to 194
that's great that's a glow up bruh
nice glow the [ __ ] up good damn my boy
it's hard to believe that same guy i
mean i mean i see it that's the same guy
but he looks he looks great good for you
dude it's a lot of progress in five
months man yeah
so anyway i downloaded the calorie thing
and uh
you know that's what i'm doing
that's all right with everybody
you got thoughts
they say you should do progress photos
nah
i'm scared i look so fat
it'll feel really good once you lose it
no progress
okay well you don't you can take them
but not uh share unless you want to
no i won't forget this ever happened
well the funny thing is that we kind of
have it just by being on camera all the
time
that's true
yeah
that's true
someone will make a compilation yeah
oh so this is really a
kind of an amazing tick tock
so there's this oh this guy is 89 real
quick yeah two things actually okay one
we have to take our ad break okay we'll
do this but two
poly shore just became a member and he's
he's chatting in our chat
and i wasn't sure if it was really him
because obviously you can just set your
name to anything but i just went into
the back end because he he um it's left
into his channel he left a super chat
and i just clicked it and this appears
to be his real youtube how much would
polly sure donate um he donated five
dollars and said i like you ethan you're
my friend
paulie i mean
pony up dude
you're like a big time that's funny
really that's how you're welcome and
just
a new fupa trooper you know he just
became a member well yeah good i like
polly stores too but you know paulie
shore net worth
i mean
30 million you got five bucks for a
small creator
small creator
yeah i'm a small creator when i'm
begging for money
when it comes to ryan cavanaugh i'm a
big creator
hi polly sure i don't know what the
heck's going on i guess i didn't see i
don't know because he commented do you
know the polish i'm so glad that he
commented
you think he wants to call in
maybe well paulie if you want to call in
i don't know how to explain that
he can message the podcast instagram if
you'd like yeah oh yeah message the
podcast instagram but don't feel
pressured to but welcome to the fam and
god bless you
bye
[Applause]
yeah saw him it's a trip when when
back in the 90s you were watching blues
clues i was watching uh biodome you're
so much more mature
biodome is the paragon of maturity hey
buddy
uh we do have to do ads though it's time
okay well before we do ads wait he just
said ethan bro chill
give me 10.
yo there you go
[Applause]
falling out a little
better guilt the man into another center
oh my god thank you paulie
got that 10 stacks baby
25 deep to poly
wow what an honor
i basically got the price of admission
of uh all my tickets i spent
going through his films back oh i just
did a full rebate on polly shore
yeah fantastic
um
okay so this is important
there's a eight this is really inspiring
okay i don't know if you've seen this
either but that's important
eight you know how you always say that
like the old people in america are like
so
resilient and they age well and they're
amazing yes okay okay
because listen
i don't know for me coming here from
israel i feel like you don't see
i agree you don't see it a lot like
people
looking young and healthy for sure
so this is what's really inspiring i
feel like i know you're setting me up
for something but i know i'm genuine no
i'm not 89 year old man makes history
this guy what he does on a bike
you will not believe age is just a
number
all right this this is inspiring man
i've never
three
two
one zero
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my god one more time
[Music]
it's like the most gnarly spill ever and
by the way
watch out this photographer just bails
he doesn't want to be any part of it
watch the sky right in front of the
camera here
watch this guy he's like
nah i'm not doing this
he didn't want his photo
like that's a pretty good photo off to
get the 80 on your guy all tangled up
and he's like nah this isn't blob
look how he builds on him bro
[Applause]
look at this guy bro he don't even look
back
yeah i mean that's pretty much death i
mean that's like pretty much
that's that right oh man
it looks good
he still looks good he does
oh man who thought this would be a good
idea
[Music]
oh good deal did you like that
did you like that clip let's see i like
the way you set that all up
paulie are you in there i feel like he
said i've been waiting for live feedback
from polly i'm gonna bleed him dry
he said blue's clues
something good about blue's clues oh
we'll read it
blue's clues is the best dude and he
donated 199 199
like like
1.99 1.99 well i guess he's it's gonna
cost him a lot of money if he wants to
continue to talk to us right
yeah
makes sense thank you for supporting me
i mean he's older than i am so what the
[ __ ] you guys you want to talk [ __ ] to
paulie shore now dan
you want to say paulie shores lying
about blue's clothes oh
oh mr paulie shore to you i would never
all right let's thank our sponsors real
fast
hbo max
we
love hbo
and this episode's sponsored by them
many of us are plunging into the depths
of our streaming platform
searching for something new to watch
looking for an entertainment fix and if
that's for true for you boy do i have
this
suggestion
getting tongue tied
you guys know where it's going hbo max
download it watch some [ __ ]
okay apparently i have to read what they
wrote
hbo max says same day movie premieres
are the biggest movies of 2021
every single month that's right the
biggest warner bros pictures releases
will be available in theaters and your
living room same day yeah this [ __ ] is
off the rails and it's free right like i
don't think you even have to buy it once
on hbo max
well and not i mean the subscription
service yeah yeah yeah but okay there's
other ones where you have to like
pay for the service and then also buy
the film and it's like okay dude right
all right so like for example dune the
movie's coming up highly anticipated
super excited for the new dune um seems
like it's gonna be awesome and if you
haven't seen it uh
suicide squad is there streaming the new
one also highly acclaimed super exciting
and fun
uh these titles and so so many more will
be available in theaters and on hbo max
for a limited time and at no extra
charge to subscriber there it is
release dates are subject to change so
get on it and sign up for hbo max at
hbom dot a x slash h3 a d link's in the
description by the way i just want to i
read the copy but just out of passion
they have like
more [ __ ] on there like they've got hub
stuff and you can watch crunchyroll via
your hbo
subscription and there's like hella good
[ __ ] or you can just watch f-boy island
that's what island turned out to be
pretty good man
started sweet but yeah
yeah the ending was great pretty happy
you watched that
i haven't seen the end yet oh the ending
made it all worth it i can't say
anything
it was great
what do you think about fy iron and
pauly shore
it will take a minute to get feedback
all right thank you hbo max we love you
app store
if you're carrying a cr oh oh oh
paulie donated five he said yeah can't
forget biodome on hbo buds
oh okay guys
no way
you guys can watch biodome on hbo that's
awesome you i wonder if he gets like a
kickback every time someone watches
probably kickback of the
i just gotta say that's one of my
all-time favorite movies biodomes yeah
yeah there was nothing like polly short
hit hard back man those polly short
movies were fighting
in the 90s yeah
son-in-law did you watch that [ __ ] in
israel was that hit or don't think so
don't be offended polly uh my wife's
from israel so she doesn't know how i'll
go and watch it yeah she'll figure it
out ceo man was good too
man classic iconic
but
i'm surprised you're still
rocking the
vernacular
once
once a buddy oh his buddy
true to himself
oh a b uh sent a photo apparently our
crew member a b and his wife
this is funny of course abby has a baby
with everybody take a picture
from uh
bro this was in novi michigan
i figured what it was that i was i think
it was like a comic con type thing or
something but
that's so funny he really tried to kick
you out of that picture didn't you
it's like half out
yeah are you are you did you pay to meet
him or what's the context here
i
no i don't
i don't recall honestly okay
he says another comment oh keep us up
who's on polish or what
polly watch
pollywatch 2021. he said hbo should be
paying out more for biodome let me tell
you oh interesting
i'll speak with uh our people about that
people helping people you give me
kickbacks via super chat i help you out
with the hbo race i know people
that's crazy
polly d
that's uh
[Laughter]
he called him paulie d yeah no
actually ironically polly d
probably was one of the jersey shores
i'll tell you
sure you're gonna like that i'm saying
this and you probably agree
paulie d
is probably way richer than paulie shore
and that's outrageous because oh no he's
not i take it back he's worth 11 million
[ __ ] that guy because a douche loser
polly's short for life polly shore is
the real paulie
shore is the real polly pauly d suck
these nuts [ __ ]
anyway we were doing an ad right
all right bring back that music if
you're carrying around a credit card
balance month after lunch month
everybody
it can feel like your never-ending cycle
of debt
upstart can help you make that final
payment so you can get ahead
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay up
your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
and it's expanding access to affordable
credit unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment define you a smarter rate for
your loan within five minute online rate
check you can see if your rate up front
for loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars you can receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payment today when you go to
upstart.com after dark that's
upstart.com after dark don't forget to
use our url to let them know we sent you
thank you thank you peace and love loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application remember that's upstart.com
slash after dark
okay
cracking
any other any updates from polly
no i'm not checking right now he's
breaking the bank trying to have the
child explain about your
this about um paulie d
paulie these really loved
what wow
oh we just got a poly show or comment
okay
i like the poly that made mtv not the
one that messed it up
right right
right
is he clown complimenting himself yes
because he was back during the heyday
event
right and then yeah the jersey shore was
like when it really started to go
downhill when it became just all reality
show folks he's the real mtv police
that's actually a good point
he's thought about that clearly yeah
clearly
that's like a thought out statement one
that's very true by the way wait people
are defending paulie d
people are saying that there's room for
both paulies and there's room in the
world for two polys yeah i guess
i was just simply asserting i'm not
saying kill apology
i don't want to
execute pauly d
what i am saying is that i like paulie
shore
better
than pauly d and my devin opinion i mean
what am i saying i'm not saying ship
them off to the
okay camps wouldn't say that
i did it
crack it
hey guys if you're interested in
investing in cryptocurrencies but aren't
sure where to get started check out the
kraken app
did i miss say something okay
with kraken you can buy and sell over 50
of the most popular cryptos like bitcoin
dogecoin and ethereum on the go
24 7. it's super easy to get started
just download the app create your
account and you're going to be investing
in minutes
one of the coolest thing about buying
crypto through kraken is that you don't
need a lot of money to try it out so
even if bitcoin is worth something like
40k you could still buy for as little as
10 dollars worth on cracking to get your
feet wet pretty cool
fantastic
find out for yourself why kraken has
been one of the highest rated places to
buy kryptos for the last 10 years
visit kraken.com
after dark
to learn more or search for kraken and
the app store we love kraken these guys
are supporting our show
we know the owner we love him send some
love go to
kraken.com thank you
and finally we have hellofresh this is
the last one please don't turn off the
podcast this is the last one thank you
thank you peace
hello fresh it seems it's a little
mismatch on the music
hello
[Applause]
all right i'll try to do it like that
let's see
hello bash
three mission patients
mouth one and seasonal
i feel like you're gonna ruin your voice
yeah that's not gonna work
what is hell fresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients with mouth
watering seasonal recipes delivered
right to your door you're going to skip
going to the grocery store and you're
going to start counting on hellofresh to
make home cooking easy fun and
affordable and that's why it's america's
number one meal kit
hello fresh you get a box just donation
yeah
get a box you've got all the portions
you need
to make a beautiful home-cooked meal
three portions you don't have to go to
the grocery store and buy like a whole
barrel of [ __ ] celery because you
just need one stick you know what i mean
right so you get it all the perfect
amount ingredients fresh
beautiful you get like the instructions
on how to cook it up perfectly and it
makes it makes cooking experience fun
because it takes all the annoying [ __ ]
right
and uh
super easy it's super easy and the food
is always fantastic it's always uh fresh
they pack it like ice they put like a
bunch of
dry ice in it so it's like nice and
fresh uh hello fresh
i love it i think it's a lot of fun you
guys have a photo of it you guys do any
cooking there recently uh i use it all
the time i don't think i have a fresh
fresh
photo but uh
but yeah i uh i i get like three meals a
week shipped to me from them oh you know
really
are you a good one recently
yeah what it uh it was like a
uh flautas
yeah lots of vegetarian options on there
so this is what's really cool is
um basically you can choose
what kind of food you want like hello
fresh
50 manual market items to choose from
every week from vegetarian meals and
calorie smart choices to extra special
gourmet options there's something for
everyone to enjoy with recipe designed
and tested by professional chefs and
nutritional experts who enjoy delicious
and simplistic simplicity meals
hellofresh offers the flexibility you
need to easily customize your order on
the app within minutes easily change
your delivery day food preference and
plan size or skip a week whenever you
need to
so here i got a special offer ready go
to hellofresh.com after dark 14 and use
code after dark 14 for up to 14 free
meals including free shipping
gabish that's hellofresh.com afterdark14
use code after doug 14 for up to 14 free
meals
uh and remember hello fresh there's a
reason it's america's number one meal
kit thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
should we watch this one more time
before we get into stuff
free age is just a number you just
remember
as we get older
college does polystore
i actually have some revealing
information that's just been shared with
me the poli shore up so now go ahead
this isn't from polly this is from
another chatter who said um
they were actually there when abe took
the pic with paulie oh no and paulie was
the one that came up with the car fire
scam
they've been in cahoots this whole time
oh [ __ ] baby
why would you reveal that yo you really
think that through
i just can't believe you've pretended to
save a kid from a burning car i mean
that's just slow man twilight movies
it's got nothing to do with twilight i
don't know why you're trying to deflect
i want it to be like a real life edward
you want to be edward
a.b cullen
somebody donated up 50
asking if there will be restocks for the
teddy fresh
august collection
their wife
loves your work and missed out on the
pink zip up because she gave birth to
her baby when it was uh being released
um
the the patchwork one i'm assuming
yeah probably yes we are going to
restock that hey there you go
good news we will restock the cat one
two um and what else
and the tattoo t-shirt
and the tie-dye shirts
hail use the chorus on this
[Music]
i just wanted to play it while i play
this
age is just a number
[Laughter]
all right let's move on
oh okay good i can work with this
i got it i got it
do you have your passport
how are you going to get you that get
your shots
[Music]
[Music]
would you like to come back
[Music]
come on everybody
america
[Music]
love do you have your passports and
shots because everyone wants to bring
you out here everyone wants love in
america i do
i i i think america has some kind of
travel done so i can't go
really oh you can't get a
no i can't get out of visa i have a visa
i can travel for three months in the us
uh without uh like proper visa because
we have a treaty
but i think there's like a travel ban
because of covet
who's banned who like on your end they
don't let you go to america or no
america is not lifting people from the
eu in really are you serious is that
still a thing that's going on what are
we here we're [ __ ] dying over here
should we go the other way around yeah i
wouldn't want acid going anywhere let
alone
okay let's move on there's a couple more
polly comments oh for real confused
it's on it's in the discord
discord just announced it i'm not
checking discord well paulie is meaning
on me as well and he said uh sorry bros
i thought it would help with a comeback
maybe we got outed i'm sorry paulie he's
copying to it yeah and then also
hashtag oh
he's slutting me
dangling to get in on the new uh
could it be polished
could it be could it be but vitamins
buddy
i'd actually love that
oh okay god i've been wanting to do this
so the matrix matrix fork is coming out
the new trailer is out
and i was obsessed with the matrix boy
that is one of my favorite all-time
movies matrix one
matrix two
matrix three
little one remember three it wasn't very
memorable
but like we've been
my first reaction when i saw the matrix
four trailer
well you know what basically i wanted to
watch the trailer with you guys but we
know where it's going to get claimed
it's probably going to get blocked so we
re made the trailer
so that we could share it with you guys
we could show it to you i think we
made some improvements to be frank so go
ahead let's watch our version of the
trailer and then we can discuss
thomas you seem triggered right now can
you explain what's going on
i have dreams that aren't just dreams am
i
crazy
we don't use that word in here
[Music]
howdy
if we met
[Music]
one pill
makes you larger
and one
makes you small
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the only thing that matters to you is
still here that's why you're still
fighting that's why you'll never give up
you don't
know me
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm neo and i'm back
given the blue option between the blue
pill and the red pill i chose the red
pill again
after all these years you're going back
to where it all started
you're going back to the matrix
[Music]
wow wow i'm hyped for that film huh
watch that that's it
i need some popcorn i don't know you get
the idea though i mean you don't need to
see the real trailer i mean
yeah you get the gist of it yeah so we
were debating
my first hunch after watching the
trailer
is that there's no freaking way this
movie's good
but as we've marinated on the idea i'm
getting kind of hyped and excited that
this might actually be a really good
film i'm i'm tentatively excited to see
i'm going to see it there's no question
yeah regardless i'm gonna get excited
but i'm i don't want to get disappointed
but deep inside i am kind of excited
i think we should do the midnight show
that's how i used to do it with this
show i'd be like first in line back in
the day they didn't have a signed
seating you had to get in line yeah you
know [ __ ] out bro you just show up at
12 throw elbows
definitely throwing elbows with my dad
throwing shivs
yeah so
so but then we were wondering like all
the possibilities you know is it a
prequel maybe
is it uh
because neo dies in the third one
right here
oh
[ __ ] right so i just watched the first
movie at 5am he watched it this morning
yeah
did you love it i did exactly i hadn't
seen it i was like i'm i'm offended
you're like i'm not letting you in the
office unless you watch the movie yeah
so was it as good as i built it up to be
it was [ __ ] really good
not better than highlander but very good
did you cry harlan
no i did not cry
is there a sad moment who's crying well
zack said that he cries very easily
i cry in the majority of the movies
especially highlander but
you seem like the kind of dude that wish
you was highlander like you just give me
hi there's a type of dude that like
highlander appeals to and you're that
i wish i was highway they're like
they're like sword fighters they're
immortals and the only way they can kill
each other is by chopping each other
chopping their heads off weird one and
it's uh it's the greatest movie
i would love to look it up but my age
doesn't work you gotta click hard there
you go
it's the greatest movie ever made either
the car girl
oh mac quality the h doesn't work wow
you want people to watch
the credit card got declined
yeah
it could be
we miss you paulie i miss you paulie
highlander i got the car the [ __ ] car
is that the movie is so good they named
a car after
no
car
no
toyota highlander
the movie bro
dude it's got action you gotta kill
people is it this
that's it
um that's your list action and kill
people the story's good you got [ __ ]
james bond in it you know it's [ __ ] a
time traveling night i don't think i've
seen it but i can't see this being
better than the main you almost
certainly have not seen it it's pretty
obscure it's so good they named a
[ __ ] car after it they for sure
didn't name the car after them
case endpoint
oh god so i don't know what do you all
think are we hyped for matrix by the way
it comes out this year
i'm hyped i just comes out in december
it's like not far away
you know i appreciate that i'm sick of
these people announcing movies like two
years ahead of time like get the [ __ ]
out of here one of my good friends uh
he didn't
provide me any spoilers or anything but
he he worked on it a little bit um and
so he had a little bit insider
information and he told me i can be
excited for it oh did he tell you
anything more than that no are you just
saying that because you want to respect
his privacy no he's no he didn't tell me
anything about it no i know he's not
allowed but i know if dan is being like
uh mom's the word with him
you trying to get my friend fired or
something no i don't know i just want to
don't say what he told you i just want
to know if you know more i don't i
legitimately don't know anything more he
just gave me a vague statement you could
tell me i'm camping i will tell you the
same who's your friend dan huh who's
your friend i will tell you the exact
same thing as i'm telling you right now
which is that i'm professional
just kidding
um
well my concern watching the real
trailer is that there was way too much
action so i was like oh this is just
going to be a total action regurgitating
you can't judge from trailers trailers
suck like john generally trailer sucks
yeah he's totally john wick and he looks
like john wick that we were joking about
[ __ ] you're not john wick you're
neo so apparently it was because they
filmed those movies like back to back
like the last john wick or maybe even
simultaneously same outfit same wardrobe
i need you to be ill for me
well maybe he shaves his head later or
something i have mixed feelings i'm
excited but i'm also scared because what
they did with terminator
i don't know if you watch the new one i
do it's just been a nightmare with
terminal well in the i'll just spoiler
in the first like minute they like
shotgun john connor to the chest and
kill him and it's like the de-aging
technology so it looks just like the
terminator 2 john connor the one that
everybody no no no no that ain't it it's
it's got to be keanu yeah
it's gotta be
right dan you know
yeah yeah see well i mean yeah i think
so i don't know an internet that would
be that would be a big twist if he was
not in the whole mood no that's not good
no i think he's gonna be in i just mean
just
destroying
the other movies by making it so bad
basically well if it's a different
timeline then it doesn't affect the
other movie yeah
do you guys so like watching the first
one kind of [ __ ] me up
because like now i'm thinking like we
are in the matrix
and it was at five in the morning so i'm
like oh [ __ ] i gotta go through the
whole day with these thoughts you know
so does it matter bro does it matter
zack's totally the guy to stay in the
matrix i'm not oh i would stay in the
matrix
i don't know [ __ ] blue pill when the
first one come out 1999.
so like it's just tripping me out like
are we on the matrix right now or
zack this conversation is like 25 years
later yeah
like i literally can't do this well i'm
not even i'm not even 25 years old yet
so
bear with me well it came out in 2000
it's 21 now so it's like a 21 year old
conversation right so are we in the
matrix yes we're in the matrix yep
well elon musk thinks we're in a
simulation so yes i guess in a way
i don't know if we're being farmed
for batteries uh by alien when has he
ever been wrong about anything
never i wonder if the alarm likes
highland
all right you guys want to get into the
next thing here
i kind of want to just keep talking
about this yeah
i kind of just have some things if
you're asking go i mean if you've got
more to say
i'm not near just like no i'm just
kidding thankfully you're you're uh
first amendment right that's controlling
my show we wouldn't
me and dan have been
had enough matrix talk we've been
nerding out about the matrix all week so
yeah we can we can move on
well thank you for your permission guys
yep you got it god bless
you it's been a while since we talked
about the self-help guru or not it's
more pick up artists
and pick up artists was a hot topic for
our channel back in the day yeah and
these guys are just irredeemably [ __ ]
i mean these are guys that are just and
ironically zack you've heard the term
red pill right that comes from the
matrix right i'm aware of that yeah okay
which is
very ironic given
uh
the views of the makers of the film the
matrix so the red pill is that
association is that like a um
wake the [ __ ] up mr anderson okay break
so you could apply that towards uh
i mean give an example
well they say taking the red pill is
like uh
you're you're
you're waking up
okay you don't accept that uh you're
accepting reality even if it's
difficult women are all
money hungry they don't care about men
they just want money and i'm gonna use
them like they use us no obviously i
don't i think that's insane that'd be an
extreme example that's what red pilling
is i mean and the terms of the pickup
stuff but
um
yeah these guys are irredeemably [ __ ]
in the head they're like in cells and i
feel like this contributes a lot to
incel
even to like
the ultimate gentleman that you know
that tragedy in santa barbara is kind of
all it's all connected to this crazy
incel dome
that treats women just like [ __ ] objects
which is super crazy but anyway this guy
i found a new uh pickup artist
and this guy is a riot i found him on
tick tock of all places
and i'm captivated
by everything about him
here's the one that i saw that started
this whole wormhole
his name is owen cook
never be a beta you understand me
god
i'm already out just never ever do it it
is death
never ever
ever do it okay just wipe down your mind
it is nothing good comes from that
ever
okay the only thing good is if you're
like in jail you're about to get shot
you're like okay okay you know other
than that if you're in a free society
don't do it it's just it's just it just
doesn't happen it cannot happen okay now
going from there and by the way the
sooner you accept this the easier your
life gets you're like oh life is
actually awesome when you accept it as
long as you don't accept tell me what
the [ __ ] that oh comes to not be a beta
like
literally what are you talking about but
by the way the top comment plots he's
standing in an empty room
that's funny but no it's not true this
man has a captive audience really
unfortunately people pay to hear this
and you're like i just want someone to
like me for the real beta me your life's
gonna be freaking me don't be yourself
this is all this is always their advice
don't be yourself be anybody but
yourself i cannot
believe this
yeah the whole dating
uh pickup artist scene is is one of the
best oh it's been that he's won so
that's very interesting
this [ __ ] is so uncomfortable
because his advice right is don't be
yourself so he's clearly not being
himself and it shows he looks so
uncomfortable in that outfit and bro
let's be honest that outfit does not
become you like that outfit becomes
nobody i don't know who the [ __ ] told
you to wear that deep scooping top under
a [ __ ] plaid rolled up in tight pants
and all this [ __ ] and everything is not
working for you dude this is the and
take it from a guy that looks like a
slob every day you look like [ __ ]
awful bro i mean the outfit
like the outfit
so just get over it i mean let's look at
the ladies he doesn't mean to walk
around paranoid
okay olivia and sam
we have fit check over here but no the
the consistent thing about him which
you'll see is that his fits are
consistently
off the charts bro this even
sam and olivia and be honest don't be
don't don't don't be mean for my sake be
honest
i mean i don't love the outfit
okay fair enough let me see let me
investigate it
that is confirmed not a fit good not
even a fit according to santa the shirt
is so low-cut it's the first thing
why is it so low cut and it's not like
he's like jacked he's not showing
anything off
the shoes
just and it's so tight the jeans
necklace so everything is a problem
everything the dog tag
yeah it just it looks like everything is
a problem dude it looks like somebody
put that outfit together for somebody
else
yes
yes
yeah maybe justin could pull that off i
don't know
thank you sam
i believe he's wearing a tank top
yeah yeah it's a wife peter right you
can't say that but can you yeah that's
what it's called it's called a wife
eater i don't know that a lot of people
these days don't even know what that
means
they don't even know that it's called
used to be called a wife beater it's
still called a wife theater
some people still say that but i think
the more used term now is tank top i do
i swear to god like i i know it used to
be called like that wait here let me
type white beater and amazon but we had
we had the ex this exact same
conversation already pulled themselves
out of people going from there
i mean i always thought that was
shocking i was like you all really call
this thing a wife eater
stop being uncomfortable yourself oh
[ __ ] me in the tip
just never shut up uh
i've always found that unusual i was
like y'all really [ __ ] call this
thing a wife beater like we all agreed
to call something a wife b maybe you
should do a poll but i feel like there's
a lot of younger people that don't even
know that that's what it is i thought it
was just a michigan thing because when i
came out here i forgot who it was never
heard of it and it actually originated
in detroit if i'm not mistaken
go ahead and do a poll
but yeah i mean i typed wifebeater and
amazon and this [ __ ] came right
up
yeah i mean i had always
used that term as well and it it's one
of those things that you don't even
think about it like obviously like
you're like wife beater yeah like that
is a horrible thing yeah you beat your
wife in this shirt
it's pretty bad like pretty [ __ ] bad
yeah oh well we call this oh this type
of shirt's called a hate crime
it's called a hate against uh jewish
people we call this piece it's a vibe do
you ever wear hate against jewish people
well i can't say that i enjoy that
silhouette yeah
yeah i mean clearly the keyword is still
in there in amazon because that's what
came up but yeah it is it is very odd
here wife peter so we're not saying wife
beater anymore is there a poll or no i
think uh yeah it's getting set up right
now yeah here wife have you heard of
wifebeater is that okay for the word
be careful
get get this off the screen
just google images for wifebeater
without vetting it beforehand i don't
know what's gonna pop up in that yeah
well regardless i'm over let's just get
to the poll yeah
i mean i'm happy to stop saying wife
peter
is the question should the question be
have you heard of the term white beater
or do you use the term one no no no cat
have you heard now i'm coming yeah no no
are we using wifebeater or are we
calling it tank tops is it offensive
what do i do
don't use it anymore
right no i just i've always just said
tank top yeah no one actually uses that
anymore
careful
i mean ethan did
what some people got to watch your mouth
girl
put on one of those tank tops
get to work oh my god
give give that name some substances
[Music]
are we doing a [ __ ] bowl or what
what are you asking me maybe
oh pin it okay i got it
you guys think i'm just here to dance
all right hey we are sending out the
poll
bro i think it's can i call it a wife
peter that i don't want to know i want i
don't want to know
the thing he set up do you say wife
beater or tank top
okay wait no this pull maybe that's fine
did you see oh my god cause i just
changed the title the first one keeper
do you use white feet or tank top yes
what the hell
ela already gave you the answer know
people don't use it you put on a b b
you can't get that bolstered
it says do you say say white feeder or
tank top yes no those are because that
makes sense i had to change the first
one all right it's updated all right we
got it we got it we got it we got it do
you say wife beater or tank cup here we
go okay here we go enough of this [ __ ]
so i just put it in the chat i'm gonna
pin it and i'm gonna spam it a little
bit okay we're off to the races here
people and it just just tells you how
many dudes were beating their wife
back in the day
they're like yeah i'll [ __ ] beat my
wife in a tank top we call it just
called a wife beater
straight in the meantime while we're
waiting for the results jed donated 50
bucks and said have you guys considered
a custom designed and custom built chair
for dan and a custom robot for lovebot
custom what do you mean
i mean a custom robot what's that gonna
run me
this is a question from a fan he donated
fifty dollars for it you're looking at
me like i'm
proposing
i'm just i'm bouncing it off you know
i'm just saying like wow i mean
um that would that would that i mean
well item chairs seemed more oh you were
going to say this ball really i was
going to say we
because i feel like that's a better gag
to give him like a six-pass bro we crash
the straw polls again
i think the custom route's probably
going to set us back a lot
yeah i guess you're right well i mean
it just depends on i mean a robot
that's a vague term it could be anything
all right well anyway let's get back to
building a gundam
let's get back to all i'm pretty
expensive
a beta never be a beta so here he is in
his audience turning a beta
into an alpha right before our eyes low
status behavior
one of the kind of keys to beginning to
break this
is actually just breaking it in the
voice
ironically if you can break this and
unstifle physically a lot of your
thinking is going to start switching on
you'll feel it happen right now as
you're speaking what's happening is
you're looking your point of orientation
is on everyone here he's going hey like
that and he's worried what you're gonna
think there's something in him that's
oriented not the right way do you see
that it's oriented in him not the right
way everything about this guy's not the
right way oh yeah
this is how to talk guys
you try to do that veda
dude
i feel
bad for everyone sitting in that room i
feel so bad for them like they've
they've come to such a frustration that
they feel like they need to listen to
this douchebag they've gone down that he
supposedly got some answers for them
that they don't know already but like
how [ __ ] lost are you to look at that
guy of all people and be like this guy
has the answers just physically his fit
alone is a
desperation i mean yeah that guy looks
better than the
supposed guru
yeah they they're literally gone down
the wrong path the the
the answer is never don't be yourself
i don't think
unless you're like ted bundy or
something
and usually the answer is also not
paying for a seminar whatever your
problem is
if somebody's
offering a seminar a paid seminar for a
solution for you
be skeptical
um i was well let's wait till my seminar
let's hold on oh i say all right yeah we
don't want to undercut our own yeah yeah
we're working on that in the background
how to be yourself by not being yourself
that was gonna be the name of mine right
[Laughter]
he's doing that is that crazy okay now
walk in the crowd a little bit go
[Applause]
what are you teaching him
[Applause]
oh bianca is an alpha as [ __ ] one of the
kind of guys
what is he doing
yeah there's there's a bunch and they're
all super entertaining and just uh
audiences
you someone want to do it for me someone
want to alpha up
i am your king betas
here low status behavior can be fixed my
dudes
fear
yeah not alpha [ __ ] bro
we're all so proud of you if there was a
single woman in there she would be so
confused and terrified
what are you teaching them
and it was used in a book huh
low status behavior part 10. we're
fixing this are you guys going to put in
your poll up or what
are you serious aby what do you mean
that paul doesn't don't use that poll
site anything i've got a wife i got it i
got it i'm
every time we use it it crashes no it's
not the regular one you didn't use
truffle what did you use i didn't use
strawberries yeah that's the one that
[ __ ] crashes every time
it's kind of epic to know how much power
yield that we can crack
i mean
it's a pretty big side i thought
[Applause]
who's the most alpha dude when you think
alpha ethan klein no no
did someone say zach
yeah suck you think zack's alph as [ __ ]
what a compliment
there's nothing more alpha than [ __ ]
on someone's lawn there you go bud i
think ela's really
oh
really let's hear you project
um we gotta pull
all right i vote wife beater for me
all right the results are in oh my i
just broke the results are not in we
have zero votes i'm spamming it so far
okay this is [ __ ] real interesting
you guys
this is
fascinating and you all need to be
apologizing to your alpha lord
because go ahead and put it up then
apologize to your alpha lord
51
that is 50 50. oh [ __ ]
when i was looking it was white feeder
well here it's i mean
it's literally 50 50. wow okay i'm
actually surprised because you know
i i think what ela said is correct
though i think the younger generation is
not carrying that term forward but
it's absolutely it needs to die i should
agree yeah i agree
i mean
can we call it steps on beater
let's not beat anybody perhaps
can we call it uh
a meat beater
the meat feeder that's better more self
self uh
i abuse myself regularly you know you're
way around some meat
okay so tank top is inching out okay
yeah
i
i'm surprised how close it is though
yeah me too actually i was expecting to
get like a 15 wipe beater and feel like
a boomer right not so boomer this day
beta
beta
all right let's continue on with ocean
oh yeah that was very illuminating
though i have to say
you ready to fix that low status
behavior
i do think that if you
if anyone was still saying it they
probably shouldn't it's just such a
weird term it's amazing yeah
but it is like dan said it's like you
don't even think about it
[Laughter]
[Music]
by the way crowder's back
huh oh good
and he's already saying like some crazy
anti-trans [ __ ] oh right i saw that yeah
so [ __ ] stupid bro he's like i had a
near-death experience and uh
and anyway i just realized the most
important thing in life coming back from
almost dying is uh to hate trans people
don't have to think about it dude i
don't have to think about it thought
through it so we get a little more punch
come on with the shouting brothers
because basically you've got to balance
the punch with the relaxedness because
if you punch too hard you're going to
lose your voice right try going as
physically hard as you can you'll
probably throw your voice up a try
yeah see that so that's too much force
now go just really relaxed but with no
with no punch
okay now get somewhere in the middle
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
this is literally a different video
anyway here i've got a link to a seminar
with a different guy that's really
interesting
uh this is another apparently a beta
that is here to be fixed by this mega
alpha
oh so so and this one this is really
cool they brought a real woman here for
the guys to train on
so this is his outfit that's like the
look
yeah that picks up chicks
so they bring a real woman they pay her
to sit there and have the guys bounce
off her but she's being patient not real
this has got to be one of the the
weirdest gigs she's like this right now
and i'm speaking to you like this right
now and i'm speaking to you like this
right now oh my god i'm speaking too
like she doesn't need it we're good just
leave it alone if i'm speaking you like
this right now and i'm speaking you like
this right now
no you no come over here
okay pop over
okay so he's looking at the ground
already he's sent can you see how tense
he looks right now okay say hello to the
audience it doesn't look tense okay so
his voice can't project and by the way
i hate to say it
you guys if you guys just insulted him
by the way you wanna know why
you literally do you wanna know my
greatest fear of being in a wheelchair
not the wheelchair
i'm not afraid
oh my god i'm talking about dude
did he say anything so far no never be a
beta all he said was you're like this
you'd be like this okay you can be like
this you're gonna be like this come over
here for a second you know what's the
biggest fear i have about being in a
wheelchair
you just insulted him by the way
afraid of a wheelchair you know what
scares me
everybody's gonna be too nice
so now if you take care of okay so
that's like a garyvee thing
go home and imagine your family being
shot in the [ __ ] basement
once we can change it and it will sit
there for five minutes and make pretend
one of them got shot in the face that's
alpha [ __ ]
gary v's alpha
eddie could have changed just from just
from this now he's like freaking out a
bit but like he's already gonna change
just from this
can you let him down marijuana
so i don't be my wife and children
right
that's alpha
get that man a wife peter
yeah so like obviously now i would [ __ ]
him that he's standing up straight like
cool good advice dude
go down all the way
up down all the way down
[Music]
even as i'm sitting here cracking jokes
he doesn't laugh you know anyone that
died
yeah who died my grandmother okay look
at that alpha kicking his legs bro
that's alpha you see him kicking his
legs i was just thinking he was going to
make a point about it or something
no he's like just a careless oh my god
um
your age
[Music]
i could have been the one that did die
like my friend john died this year
why are you doing this with your legs at
what point are you going to give them
actual advice i'm sorry this guy is
creepy wait do you see that thing is not
right with this guy oh for sure for sure
for sure he hammers at this kid for
about a good hour
there's four minutes right yeah yeah
four minutes yeah yeah there's an
emergency and you guys all don't see it
here he's supported what happens when he
goes home alone look he's barely laughed
at a single joke how do you this has
been pretty funny you were dying a joke
it's not funny and you're humiliating
him bro where's the part where you help
him
[ __ ] it up man
be a man figure it out
oh my god i hate this
part of being a man is kicking your feet
like a little [ __ ] what else are you
mad about
what if you could have just want to go
give this guy a hug look at his hand so
nervous
are your parents super rich or no no
what if you've been a six foot two male
model with your parents super rich
why couldn't you been born like that
why couldn't you have been that what are
you or maybe a beautiful woman
why couldn't you have been that
strong you need to get out of here well
think about how much like insecurity
there has to be for him to even go to an
event like this
he's just getting ready this kid just
wrecks him though do you hear what he
said he goes i wouldn't want that
oh interesting
yeah
but like dude first of all this guy
looks totally normal by the way the guy
next to him you know the kid there's
nothing wrong with this it's just a
little uncomfortable a little insecure
like exactly just be yourself bro that's
confidence comes from
self-security not pretending you're
someone else damn
but the point is
um
what would be a reason not to though
i think it's okay to admit you'd want it
but what's what would be a good but what
would be a good
path or thing you have no idea given
that you didn't have it
because by the way
i think the first levels are like i'm
glad this happened because it gave me
this and this and this i feel like
another level is being like oh i'm not
glad it happened but
it did give me this opportunity because
i almost feel like having to pretend it
was awesome like i don't even pretend
he's pissed off him to be okay because
the kid did answer and he said i don't
want that so now he's trying to speak
over him and not give him a chance to
speak and bullying him into saying you
do wish you were six foot model
rich kid
i have a thing
this guy has no idea
that sucked but
here's the opportunities it gave me and
i'm to work them and hey i'm alive
i i'm okay to just go with that do you
wish you're born a six foot two male
models let me ask you for experience i
do but i wasn't so i have angles i can
take i probably wouldn't be running the
seminar if i'd done that right
so do you wish you're born no
legs
are you just saying that because i told
you to say it or do you believe it
oh
it's good not
to
his brain is so shut down he can barely
talk because
yeah so
here's the update this is i think
there's one specific video i saw with
this guy somebody said this guy is
dwight schrute yeah big twice food
energy here's the true
transformation
oh here he is
he's transformed
look at his face
he's getting flooded with brain neuro
chemicals right he's not used to feeling
like this it feels good
and he can probably think more clearly
now
how do you feel as far as your thinking
as you're doing that can you feel can
you have a little bit more awareness
bro shut the [ __ ] up
that guy went to pacsun and bought up a
flannel in every color
they did
so here's the craziest fit of all time
look at this [ __ ] whoa so here he is on
the street
doing by the way this has 400 000 views
420 000 views and almost all
like 100 likes so this is not some small
time [ __ ]
this guy has a captive audience like
let's look at the comments
bro you look like a gta vice city
character 10 out of 10.
they're saying wow that girl left her
dude for tyler
yeah they love it
main three takeaways go within yourself
and be i'm not reading this
but get a look at this guy's fit it's
not rocket science is that people tend
to gravitate
towards higher energy it's like why do
people watch you know a rock movie or
something like that why do people what's
up guys why do people why do people
um you know gravitate towards that they
gravitate towards energy they gravitate
towards positivity
you know what i'm talking about right
yes i do are you okay to be in the video
by the way i am like all above like
meditation and like epic
huge
when you see energy around
you have to go
no i'm trying to listen to you okay hug
then
good night
good to meet you you're okay to be in
the video dude because you're you're
you're like
oh
boy
this is the worst thing i've ever seen
in my life
i am such a player bro yeah a drunk girl
saw a camera and
that was just the power of energy dude
people will gravitate towards those who
have higher energy it's just a known
fact why do people walk watch a rock
concert why do people watch all this
crazy stuff on television they do it for
the very simple reason that people do
gravitate towards stimulation people are
bored they go towards simulation
i think it's earlier where you see the
full look why do people when you have to
why do i go back back you got to see the
full fit that is because i actually want
to start off by showing you the research
so a big part of my
time stamped it sorry guys i don't know
the ways that i can often yeah you could
see him sitting down
god damn it where is it
he has his cameraman
film his other cameramen right and it
usually goes into an area where there's
a lot of people and the reason why i
want to do that is because
by showing you the reason that a lot of
people do use a higher energy to go out
and meet people because i feel like
before we go into the lower energy
ways of going about it
at the same time we should at least
acknowledge why a lot of people use a
higher energy now the basic reason which
you can probably guess i think it's not
right where is this
it says 610. no no no no there's
specifically a shot you need to stay
trustworthy
yeah yeah this is it maybe one employee
has a lot going for them but they act
weird in a couple different ways whereas
another employee might have some stuff
done for them
but they're not acting weird at all
often times they're gonna go with the
employees yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so oftentimes what happens
when you meet yeah you gotta see this oh
you dropped it look at this fit and then
somehow they would just get to talking
and as they get to talking things would
go from there and they would live
happily ever that's oftentimes a fantasy
that i see come on people that are just
a bit more chill so to me
if you're coming he's not saying
anything no he's not saying anything
with stimulation
that's pretty clever he kind of looks
like an inversion of keemstar in a way
you're not the first to say it people in
the chat yeah it looks like the casey
beta i mean keem is beta though so what
would you call a beta star
gamma star gamma star amore have we
figured out what a gamma male is yet is
that uh i don't think that male 1
because i know there's alpha beta and
sigma but what's up with gamma males no
the gamma males haven't dropped yet
that's due for next year
oh beta they're arguing no there are
guys
gamma male
explained go ahead so stupid game of
males are intellectual highly romantic
ideological driven men
who hold a lower status position in the
social dominance hierarchy though they
desire to be leaders and
rank and privilege that comes to natural
alphas and betas
it seems like all the non
alpha ones are just like wannabe alpha
beta beta plus
they're saying is a hipster bench
shapiro
i can't get over this guy man it's like
greg paul and keemstar fused
thank you zac greg paul plus the game
star i'm a [ __ ] savage you gotta do
it there's an omega mail
oh [ __ ] what's the the end of all males
what does that mean
uh
self-assured driven intelligent
uh diversified interests i mean
me
this comment she's saying they're like
covet variants
right the different male 1
their total variance
yeah this guy's tick tock is pretty wild
though i recommend checking it out i i
think i follow him now
a woodcock self-help
we're like self-defeat
so we have crea okay you ready for some
weird
kink talk
oh no
yes so king how long we've been going by
the way uh dan
uh an hour and 43 minutes oh
oh
all right so king talk is i guess well
olivia you put this together
it's
yeah i did
it's just a bunch of uh
it's mainly young boys
being
kind of crazy being dominant yeah thirst
trapping yep
now does this do anything for you uh do
you get this at all this king this uh
this uh thirst trapping um luckily it's
not on my for you page and no no it does
not
what about you maybe
yeah
whatever olivia just said i'm sorry i
was reading we accidentally but we put
paulie shore in a timeout automatically
that wasn't us we love you wait what
happened to paulie is he still in the
chat what happened to paulie yeah
because i think he was spamming tomatoes
at the last uh dude and it oh paulie's
participating in china he's spamming
bananas
for tomatoes
apparently yeah
how funny he's a big fan dude
what we're learning
timeout is just a temporary yeah it'll
be released momentarily um by the way
our auto mod tomato polish that's right
maybe you just agreed um
that kink talk does something for you
yeah oh thank you for that olivia you
just said yeah for sure and i trust you
i don't want to trust you
yeah none of us do anymore
so here's kink talking it's pretty weird
bro i'm going to come
yeah
what children said it does nothing for
you
and i said it does something for a b
yeah he said yeah well because a lot of
these have a lot of views so it does
something for somebody
here it is ela you tell me what you
think
babe come here i have to write a message
first you can write it later
stop looking at and wait
pulls you by the neck that wasn't a
question
69 i owned that
so it's just
pov
abusive boyfriend you're dating
okay
well the top comment is this gave me
butterflies oh boy
sir i may have accidentally just fell in
love with you
[Laughter]
these povs are getting better and better
wow so yeah it's like what does he own
her yeah her that ass
you don't you wouldn't say i own that
ass
i thought i owned that app
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
love
okay here we go
this one has 200 000 likes so that that
is significant
he says trust me it's worth it oh god
bro all right
open your mouth and stick your tongue
out trust me
[Music]
okay
trust me it's worth it
um
look in my eyes what is that's what's
going to feel ben well you're being uh
you're being a submissive girl you're
sticking out your tongue and he's
spitting in your mouth what don't you
get
a girl asked me to spit on her once
didn't ask
read it take it easy on them just
kidding don't take it too serious
oh you're worried they're going to be
mean to me
really i am probably
that was a [ __ ] curveball
i thought it was funny well it's like
evie's always
offering up these like crazy sex stories
you know
okay what happened to girl
or whatever
no nothing and did you i did not no i
did not
did
what did she say exactly
i don't know [ __ ] that girl because now
that moment led to this moment
twice was it the donkey kong bingo girl
no
that's what she said
so you guys were mid the act were you
doing the act you were having a quite
old moment you know what i want to share
i'm not going to share this story i'm
going to keep this one to myself
i'm going to keep it to myself i didn't
[ __ ] ask for it you brought it up now
you want to keep it to yourself i'll
keep it to myself
never be a beta
okay you're the one who brought it up
i'm just asking questions
that's not that interesting that's it
okay
[Applause]
so the comments on this one are
this gave me butterflies oh you see that
oh okay don ark's i'm full affected not
in the middle of a pendant not me
someone in with some
some sense
someone said not me doing it twice i
guess she like she's into it yeah
someone said not me actually almost
puking over here okay
someone said why did i actually swallow
it too
i need to go outside and touch grass
goodbye
hi
this girl said i really said thank you
afterwards
it's your fault i fall in love
somebody tell me why i actually listened
good girl
how he responded to her that was him he
said good girl
[Laughter]
someone said i spitted it out
very nice
yeah so it's pretty interesting there's
so much going on on tick tock right
here's another one
it's a strange place
uh this one is 60 000 likes pov
you accidentally act out of anger to
your toxic boyfriend oh so this is toxic
boyfriend
interesting
because i kissed you is that the problem
because i kissed you is that the problem
oh oh [ __ ] stop treating me like i'm
struggling
did you slap me
you're lucky we have people over
i'm not scared of you
i guess uh i mean jesus christ
threatening to beat her up later i guess
yeah
maybe the term wife beater is coming
back yeah
[Laughter]
somebody said take toxic
tick-tock tick tock got him uh here's
another one
um
oh the same guy okay fantastic from the
first guy he's got a whole series
uh you babe i'm bored can we go
somewhere else
um
who i don't cares uh you're the worst
boyfriend the [ __ ] you say to me
grabs you by the neck oh my god
don't you see
i got everything you need
please let me go
apologize
dead
yeah uh oh what is this pokeman somebody
made a donation and said shout out to
pokemon wearing uh teddy fresh on her
stream right now no one checked and sure
enough out
i look pokey
also um do you guys want us to order
food
uh does the pope [ __ ] does the pope eat
or
[ __ ] let me check my calories because i
had that
i had that sandwich
um today right
okay i'll do some more super transparent
okay well this is great actually i have
800 calories left so that's a pretty
nice that's a healthy that's a healthy
chunk so that i could get like a [ __ ]
burrito for that called today right
[Music]
you wanna you're gonna get hungry again
i gotta wrap it up
you're gonna get hungry later yeah i'm
gonna get hungry
that's how it works can anyone talk
sense to him
last caught
if you slam a big burrito now you could
be good for the rest of the day thank
you dan but he wouldn't oh i got it
locked it up
you gotta lock it up i'm not sure i know
what that means no more food it's like
okay it might get hungry lock it up all
right oh okay
the stomach it's locked the refrigerator
netflix on headaches yeah i get
headaches i'm like starving to death i
go ela i think my body's cannibalizing
my brain instead of my back
i don't think this is working
lock it up are you still are you still
working out as you do this
well i was just asking we have plans for
it we have guests my brother's staying
with us and he's yeah tomorrow my
exercise equipment is but we're going to
move it all to the basement since we're
out of the basement right then i'm going
to have my i have a whole calorie
crushing
basement
oh
yeah some alpha [ __ ] dude
that's some alpha [ __ ]
if you want me to project my voice again
just let me know
turn some of you ladies on
uh last one about from kink talk what do
you want to eat though you should decide
me
but if you want something like shake
shack then i just no i don't want shake
shake
shake shake
you want mexican you want something else
i don't care i'll take whatever you got
i don't know i'm fine right now oh
you're not hungry
i i am but i don't i don't want to do
this live i have no idea
oh i got a little didgeridoo going
what the hell you did you're doing over
there boy did you do you got me so upset
over the hell you did you're doing you
got me [ __ ]
[Music]
that's good all right so this is the
last third strap here we got
uh this one says uh
i don't know all right i think i'm able
to stand up now sir
okay round two
uh he's got a chain so oh god okay oh
all right i don't know i don't know god
this is so strange what else the guy got
in his account i'm wondering everybody
keeps um
spamming the chat about
jordan
cheyenne
a family oh the family channel oh so are
you familiar yeah i can talk about it
but i can't listen we saw it on youtube
you can't show kids in distress yeah oh
so you know the story okay yeah we saw
the video
i'll describe it i can't show the video
it's awful so there's this bro
apparently this woman
is a vlogger she has like 600 000
subscribers on youtube so fairly big
channel
and i think she forgot to edit out this
part of her trying to get a thumbnail
with her son
who appears to be about
12 i don't know really young
and um
maybe younger than 12.
yeah i'm bad at getting younger 10 9 i
don't know
so
what's funny
nothing about this story
why are you laughing
he said i'm bad at guessing ages i was
gonna make a comment about the blues
clues thing again
i don't want to do i don't want to
derail this i'm sorry i'm talking good
luck no she never said anything or
laughing they're giggling out loud
because i like
it it was
[Music]
[Laughter]
so um
so family vlogger she's with her son 10
let's say i don't know
and i don't know what was the context of
the video but something sad happened the
title of the video was uh were
heartbroken i think they're like giving
away their dog or something i saw
i think i saw someone yeah that'd be
suffering virus oh no yeah
so this poor kid
he's actually crying he's very upset
yeah and the mom goes okay okay no
now coming come in here come here for
the thumbnail
yeah he goes no put you now put your
face here and she's like she's like he
goes but mommy i'm actually crying and
she goes no no no no but open your mouth
more open your mouth don't cover your
face don't cover your face put your hand
here but don't cover your face and then
she goes up she did she bet he's like
mommy i'm crying and like he actually
just wants his mom yeah yeah he's eight
years old oh he's eight yeah
he actually just wants his mom like in a
genuine like plea for for her yeah and
she's like so [ __ ]
unaware of his actual emotional needs
and just the sickness of like
the sickness of like making it so
theatrical like it doesn't look sad
enough you gotta look sadder it's crazy
yeah and like it's obvious he was
playing along because he knows that's
how he like
uh wins his mom's affection he needs to
do it for her it's his mom telling him
to do something but it's heartbreaking
how he's like mom i'm actually crying
you know yeah
um and honestly it's so [ __ ] you can
watch it all over the internet it's all
over but it's so disturbing
and it honestly makes me think like is
it time to just outright ban family
channels from youtube because there's no
oversight there's no people these these
family channels are all [ __ ] up
yeah there's nobody involved to look
after the welfare of the kids because
the parents have a conflict of interest
their business cannot be [ __ ] fueled
by their kids it's a conflict of
interest and there's nobody else
involved to oversee that and make sure
it's healthy i think it's a great point
somebody gotta take care of these
[ __ ] kids
i'm green
you don't know i need that clout it's
just like kids in the
in the well in the mainstream
entertainment industry
and you know hollywood had a long
history of abusing the crap out of those
kids there's a lot of laws now to
protect kids and there's a lot yeah
there's very at least on on studio
movies and everything you know the kids
are only allowed to work a certain
number of hours they're always
supervised they they have tutors there
and everything that said it
should i'm sure still it happens and
it's still bad but at least there's some
degree
of oversight yeah
because this stuff just happens you know
there's no oversight at home or whatever
exactly at any hour of the day you don't
know exactly
well you always see it during these
candid moments like you saw from the ace
family right they had their kids and
they're like i forget exactly what
happened but they accidentally uploaded
it was something kind of similar where
they were like redoing the intro or a
thumbnail too yeah and they just left it
in but you see how the kids are just so
like rehearsed
yeah
and they were like really having a sour
moment and acting happy right
and um
well it just broke my heart and it was
just disgusting to see
and the part the problem is that
everybody dog piling on this mom and
like i'm sure there's like people taking
them way too far trying to get the kid
taken away from her stuff it's like if
you i i just don't think that breaking
up the family is probably what's good
for the kid
the truth is that this [ __ ] just should
not be happening in the first place yeah
there needs to be oversight and some
regulations
like i don't it's just like how they
removed all comments on kids videos yeah
it needs to be some kind of solution
like that like there is no room for i
don't think like i think there needs to
be a role like kids under 13 shouldn't
be allowed in youtube videos straight
[ __ ] up
like that's the role on tick tock and i
think instagram if you're under a
certain age you just can't post [ __ ]
right so i don't i mean on youtube
i think they need a similar role at this
point the kid's under 13
you can't [ __ ] post him
because it's just not safe
and it incentivized parents in the worst
way possible
and the problem is they get lost in the
sauce they forget that they're supposed
to be a parent first
they they put the career over their
parenting in certain ways and uh i think
they get i don't i'm not i don't know
anything about this woman if she's a bad
parent or not ever just a horrible
moment that was caught on camera
whatever it was it was bad it's going to
cause a lot of problems in their family
now because it's out there and everyone
i'm sure everyone's being like cold
child protective we gotta get put this
kid in foster care that'll be better for
him right
but the point is it should never happen
right
blood boiling i say
dude kids under 13 not allowed in
youtube videos
yeah i definitely agree with that
thank you
i don't know though what the [ __ ] do i
know
but i don't hate the idea
yo sad horrible
he's had laryngitis recently i don't
know what's going on with her
so we did that oh you a creepy talk is
okay king talk
we have mobile you got to watch these
mobile game ads dude yeah dan's been
pushing this one for a while so
okay so ela
mobile game ads
apparently are getting like so crazy
um
dan has uh prepared some of the ukraine
well here's a tour
yeah watch look at the twitter threads
first okay so here here's an example i
guess these are what like uh
you're using a mobile app and then this
is the kind of [ __ ] that pops up yeah i
mean we've all seen it if you're
scrolling instagram or any other social
media you know there's lots of ads for
for mobile games and the mobile games
themselves you know already have this
reputation of being told dog [ __ ] in the
vast majority of cases you know it's
just shovelware
companies just pump it out or whatever
but the ads for them have really they've
they've been
escalating the level of insanity in the
ads for for a while now and it's
reaching a critical point okay well here
we go
merge mansion which apparently is just a
bejeweled is that right it's like
literally just a jew almost all of them
are which you wouldn't expect at all
it's like one of these dumb jewel games
it's like tetra you know it's
all the boomers play it okay bedazzled
or bejeweled what do they call it yeah
with where you just flip gems
patterns or whatever and yeah
so her house burned down
nana's calling her
consoling her
damn she'd been through so much with
anna
nana bought her that house
nana helped her clean it up
the memories we've had
the memories we've shared
oh okay so she's i guess this isn't a
flashback she's fixing up the house
but wait nana got arrested
hold on
nana
i'm gonna get you out
nana holds up enough looking between
he's alive what
[Laughter]
who is alive
he is damn it
pretty uh pretty wild well she was
coming back from a funeral at the
beginning oh okay
so so sinister perhaps right
uh here's another right so what does
that imply that happened
well here's another alternate ending did
they fake the death of her husband to
get life insurance sure looks like it
huh yeah and see they have multiple
versions what you're about to play is a
is an alt take if you will yeah so
here's merch merge mansion and maybe uh
uh give you a different insight nana's
in the police car
but wait sinister twist
what does it say
i planned this
down that sick freak
wow they really know their audience it's
like life insurance jokes
right
because it's old people yeah it's right
oh
interesting oh that's
it's just rumors because i noticed like
i noticed so many boomers playing those
like bedazzled games yeah it's big with
that yeah they're like life yeah because
nobody cares about life or home
insurance this isn't my first rodeo
um so i actually i i made like a uh i
mean you could just browse the thread
too but i i edited a ton of them
together which is the number okay so
let's just play let's see in fact the
first one was that one that we just
watched so you can just skip ahead like
a minute should i watch these are these
in it
there's some that aren't in that twitter
thread that watch this one bro this [ __ ]
is so crazy
you are the father you are not the
father checking the dna
also the baby's black
he throws the [ __ ] baby
and starts breaking down yeah
and this just shows up on your phone as
you're scrolling oh my god this is
really
obscene and then here's one with the
black guy
are you the father
nope
so here's a super cut of uh
crazy video game ads for your viewing
pleasure
courtesy of dan yeah skip forward to
like a
50 seconds in or so to skip that one
that we just watched with nana
got it
[Music]
inspiring
so we've got you like the last one it's
like a head massage game
[Music]
you can cro oh it's a chiropractor
snap the neck
[Music]
you must make a choice between the baby
and the dino
why would you save the bees don't worry
he would he saves the kid however
he got a shark kill
[Music]
and the baby ate the shark
let's go
turned into a babe oh she 18 years later
boy
oh my god so now these people are
walking down
right now
what why would you lie
okay so they're trying to get into
heaven your teenage daughter oh my god
wait i got a pup your teenage daughter
is six months pregnant do you
find the father or kick her out
nice option
doesn't seem like that challenging of a
question
kick her out and then your ass fall down
to hell
you're f you farted in front of her
parents
blame the dog or pretend not to notice
are they just trying to make like the
most weird
game that might become viral because
it's so weird
i guess they're all just trying really
hard but also almost
almost like i said almost all of these
end up just being a bejeweled game and
as you'll see and as you'll see like for
most of them
most of them the ad has like [ __ ]
nothing to do with that so really it's
just like they're just completely lying
about what they're doing well they're
just trying to get cap yeah they're yeah
[Laughter]
so apparently
oh paulie's back we got a comment from
paul shore oh did we let me
yeah he said oh cool i'm not banned
we have a bot that times people out if
they spam too much so i think he would
spam in the tomatoes or something and it
was bound for 300 seconds there you go
so apparently
so apparently blaming a fart on the dog
will put you closer to hell which is
interesting
well we're not sure let's see
let's see yeah he's going to help help
he bad choice yeah obviously you know
you'll never reach him
this was the one we saw
dude with the black baby
dna i mean
i think you need to analyze the dna for
that one but
and he throws that [ __ ] baby
you are not the father
oh okay back to heaven are you part why
are you serious right now
you can't be serious this is a real
question
what are you part of the lgbtq plus yes
or no
three steps to heaven elohim
i wonder why i don't understand
sexual orientation how are they allowed
to run this yeah this shouldn't be this
this seems homophobic or this is gone
they're almost so who is gay
no or yes
bro
that can't be real
did cam made this
no you make that can that is that is 100
percent
no emphatic no because obviously we're
kidding
he doesn't want that cam doesn't want
that heat
and i got news for you that means you're
gay
can you imagine having to work on that
here how about this are you jewish yes
or no
i'm i feel like that's probably in that
game yes you're going to hell but that
probably is there i'm anti-semitic have
you ever masturbated yes or no
you're going to hell boy
have you ever attended a oh here's a
good one have you ever
participated in moving around a priest
accused of uh essaying a small child
yes you're going to have you're going to
heaven
baby
the pope is waiting for you
zombie apocalypse game
he's got a bigger [ __ ]
he just he killed himself family
he just ended his own life in his own
family's life casually as [ __ ] yep
okay so some of them are live action and
these are actually my favorite this one
that's coming up wait i gotta go back
cause this guy just ended his whole life
he sees it he's just like and he didn't
even consult with this girl it's just
like a pocket
i love how fast it cuts away from that
okay so this is a live action immortal
diaries supernatural lovers yeah i
really enjoy this one
he already has a high level title how
could he feel like a civilian like you
[Music]
you
and your
[Music]
because i'm playing
that's probably the lower budget option
than the cg yeah it probably is yeah
they seem to have thick russian accents
i can't imagine many people clicking for
that to be honest
all right where is this going
[Music]
what
dude
this is kind of cool
this one's pretty interesting
yo is that the real game player
i mean because that's actually looks
sick
and it's just i like how they name it
like it's a normal game guns and glory
they're literally catapulting naked bald
men
this game actually looks good should we
download this one yes i do i'm actually
curious it's called guns and glory can
someone play that and tell me if that's
what it is or just be jeweled
let me make sure i got the name right
it's called uh
guns and glory right or guns of or i
think it's
glory it's only on the guns of glory i
don't know it's on apple as well guns of
glory okay i'm really interested
is going to pee
the rest of the game it i don't it
doesn't seem goofy at all
wow at least i'm like dude that's all
[ __ ] up because that game looks sick
yeah what does it look like
just like a pirate
game it's not even related to what i
just watched it doesn't like that look
like a tower defense kind of thing where
you have like swarms of stuff coming in
and you have to defend this doesn't look
anything like that
well if people are clicking for that
game just make that game i don't know
man the cover photo says legendary
pirates yeah
it's just like pirate game are we
looking up the right game i mean i know
it says guns of glory
but i don't know why it's written all
weird
oh because there's a
there's a water mark there's a there are
i am seeing a lot
there's a lot of things called guns of
glory
guns of glory
i don't know man okay fair enough
do you have a car yes i do
a primary this video came out do you
have a house
of course in beverly hills yeah
do you have a job no it's a job when you
have
day outs
this is so [ __ ]
are you sick
straight up just a scam put in your
paypal paypal
who needs a job when you have the app
word relax paid you thirty dollars ready
to go to beverly hills
damn this is [ __ ] insane dude
all right elo we're back on we just
started a new one
he's there with nana
he's chugging water and nana's like can
i have some water and he's like [ __ ] you
nanny
this wine is good stuff oh he's raging
some husbands divorce or tolerate oh
[ __ ] there now they're
now they're
dying of cold we went back to my
grandma's old house
oh heat up the flame
okay that's a good idea oh god they're
tearing up the floor to burn
those are tough times man
oh [ __ ] now they to fix the heater
okay screwdriver good idea
oh no oh no that
heater exploded
then you're trying to fix the wall oh
they knocked the wall down help them
oh this is the same people right
matchington mansion these people are and
again it's probably just bejeweled
wow
these people have an imagination i'll
say that
this got to be the same people too
they all have very similar style don't
they did love really fall asleep
i mean i know it's super late for him
you love
let's hit wait did he really
did you fall asleep love
no
oh why did you just go to bed you poor
guy no i actually didn't you're just
kidding okay
i was like you can go to bed
well the reason i did it was because the
shots were spamming that i joined
earlier oh you're doing a gag so i just
thought
[Laughter]
you killed me in the
the clip where you guys play the trisha
clip
and then it comes to you guys and love
is the joji face oh yeah he always pulls
the joji face
no respect he pulled that joji face on
me so fast
yeah could you not play that dramatic
i'm just kidding it's funny
okay so we're moving on to a new ad this
is by the same freaks pregnant wife
and god what is going on inside there
what is going on here
she's like shaving his legs with the
straight razors and he's holding his
head
so the pregnant wife says she's do you
endure do you leave
that's your options
[Music]
what let's see she picks leave
oh [ __ ] she's pregnant
[Music]
bruh
so wait she's not pregnant she pretends
being pregnant you know
she throws her in the ocean
and now you have to save her
[Music]
what the [ __ ] okay this next one is the
wildest by far
she's uh on the washing machine
don't tell me she's getting off
you can't be oh my god
this can't be an add-on this is not a
real ad
[Music]
no
this is not
a real ad
who would allow that on their platform
i mean it's facebook they don't check
anything god
well beheading videos on there
talk to the hand
you can slap it okay wow now that's a
slap
that's that's how you treat a lady
that's alpha get this man a wife peter
yo he slapped the [ __ ] out of her what
he sent her into a different zip code
boom dude
[Music]
oh my god this game is [ __ ] insane
i've seen people in the chat saying uh
they've seen that ad
oh wait i can't believe it yeah the
washing machine one what
so she oh a fish bites her ass
dude rescues her oh my goodness
what the hell
so there's a see at least this one shows
you that it's bejeweled
wait how'd they show it's beginning
go back because i just saw cool ass
zombie fighting
right here this ah
okay so it's like a story driven
bejeweled
i mean
i mean this looks kind of cool
i'm barbara
hey barbara i had a lot of boyfriends
okay
[Music]
but because of my brother
you can only be mine
her brother wants to [ __ ] her
that's the plot
dude you cannot be [ __ ] serious
that's the plot her brother wants the
[ __ ] yes indeed
and where do people see these ads on
facebook facebook instagram all over the
place sam just last night sent me
because we were talking about it and she
sent me one that she had just been
served on uh instagram
what was it it was uh
it was another one like the uh the
washing machine one i think oh
it wasn't that one specifically but it
was another one for that same game okay
well anyway we actually
will we say you know there's a lot of
money in mobile games
so we're here to pitch our own mobile
games
really yep i think we have some good
ideas here we do
uh nanny mansion uh a little new twist
ending keemstar snitch
he writes on hand
was keemstar that's niched all along
guns and glory it's a dan instead
sight to man saita dan said to dan
uh this is the um
ethan the uh immortal diaries ethan the
vampire player
people in the chat saying they get these
kind of ads on youtube as well
wow yeah that is unbelievable
blown away by that
uh this is uh
you are not the father you are the
father
so
it's a robot edition it's pretty
compelling stuff you don't know
the truth
so
i guess that's it that's all just a
couple old dudes yeah thank you thank
you
all right
that's it that's all we got go people
people want a baby update
sure go ahead
um
[Laughter]
there's not much to tell
um
i just checked i think yesterday it says
the baby is the size of a mango that's
pretty big man those are big fruits
those are one of the bigger fruits yeah
besides the melons of course starting to
see the cakes they showed ethan i can't
believe there's a baby inside you
kicking like i just can't believe yeah
it's
yeah
pretty crazy
and
that's it
next week next week we have the final
finally we have the ultrasound we're
getting no no the gender next week and
i'm sure it's a girl oh
nice i mean that's my guess
but we were right with theodore we were
both like it's a boy yeah i know i know
it's probably [ __ ] but we have this
very strong intuition that is going to
be a girl but i i sometimes wonder is it
just because i want it to be a girl
though i'd be happy for another i'll be
happy for anything i love you yeah i
love my babies
of course
somebody is uh asking for a mr verified
update
[ __ ] i keep forgetting that you know
should i send the email right now
yes
all right let's drop they also keep
asking for a free check but i always i
feel like there's no way to do it it's
like i stand up and you don't see
anything get my foot checked
you know don't be modest fashion music
there you go
work it turn it around flip
yeah yeah i could turn my camera
give it give me twirl show off the
necklace the shirt the shoes put the
shoes on the table those are fly dude
those shoes are fly
[Music]
show the shoes come on don't be modest
[Music]
damn hell yeah come on
[Applause]
i got i bought ethan shoes show your
shoes
oh he was making me wear these birkins
she was tired of me wearing the teddy
fresh flip-flops
well because it wears it everywhere yeah
well i'm representing
well anyway ela got me some birkenstocks
you guys think it's an upgrade
nothing's better than teddy fresh but
this variety is nice
don't people
are birkenstocks good
yes yeah i actually went to go buy some
over the weekend and i saw what they
were and i was like [ __ ] that okay i
thought people memed on those or
something but maybe i'm confusing it was
something else i'm not aware
all right i'll put it you want i'll
gonna i'm gonna write the email you
wanna give me some typing
[Music]
dear
instagram
employee
maybe something more
give me a different well that was the mr
verified music was white yeah no i get
it but
yeah this is good well this is sad
it's sentimental more sentimental yeah
dear instagram employee i have a letter
of great importance to
bring to you today
ian slater
a loyal
and great man
one of the greatest men
i know
is in great
need
of verification
on your beautiful platform
i know he will bring
countless
dozens
of people
to your platform
it will be
a wise business decision
and make
and make this make a wish
and make this make
this a make a wish moment
is that offensive or fine
calling it a make-a-wish moment yeah
you're making his wish to be verified
come true
yeah it's a make-a-wish moment some
people are saying i should do the fit
check on uh tick tock
and i i wonder how i feel like i just i
still don't get tick-tock you know what
you should do i don't know how to do it
let me give you an idea i've seen people
do this and i think it would work for
you because you you you do the voice
over so you but i don't like i'm too
embarrassed to do voices well you got it
yeah i mean you've got to get used to
you want me to do the voiceover for you
i think you'll get used to it pretty
fast once you work through it but you
like just get your full body in the
mirror then you can do the bracelets the
necklace the shoes
do the full look and then you go here's
my outfit for today and if you don't
like it then you can leave
thank you goodbye good morning queens of
tick-tock above 18. i feel like
tick-tock is not bro shy people
you could add text instead
you could put text on the screen if you
don't want a voiceover
yeah but i think the voiceover would be
strong
i'd love to do it with you i think i can
just ease you into it
because i think i like i understand
you're shy but you can work through it
and then you'll get comfortable doing it
because think about all the other things
that you were too shy to or that you
weren't comfortable doing that you've
become comfortable doing now by just
kind of working through it because i
think your videos would be popular
i'll try it
yeah why don't we try one
together
forever
okay so back to this dear instagram
employee
i have a letter of great importance to
bring you today ian slater a loyal and
great man one of the greatest men i know
is in
i said great like 10 times is in is in a
dire
need of verification on your beautiful
platform
i know he will bring countless dozens of
people to you to your platform it will
be a wise business decision and and make
this a make-a-wish moment
yeah maybe maybe not the make-a-wish
part on the second thought okay so you
take that out yeah
can i say you have like a
a uh
a deadly disease is that what you're
about to say yeah that might help
[Music]
i'm gonna get banned after this email i
think
i know if he will break uh so okay
how about this how about like if you do
not comply within
seven days
do not comply with seven days
i will i will
find out
where you live
and there will be consequences
govern yourself accordingly burn
yourself accordingly
help
accordingly um
i will make your life a living hell
i know people
i know people i'm a dangerous man
a dangerous fan
make this happen
or else
sign
yours truly
with good faith and good health
with the fondest of
consideration
and dearness to my heart
and
everlasting uh respect and
admiration
yours forever
ethan fine
you nailed it i mean i wrote the whole
thing here it's just a matter of sending
it
well
you think that's gonna work
i think you should move it to the draft
and we can yeah iron out the details
okay i don't know if you're even typing
over there i think you're just playing
like guns of glory
here it is look i typed the whole
[ __ ] thing
can i show this uh is that my email
don't show it don't show it you can't
see anything i mean it's just dana it's
true everyone knows that's your email
[Music]
no i i know that my email's public but i
don't know if there's stuff you could
see on the i mean just to be safe i made
sure you can't see anything we believe
you you wrote the list this is an email
with dan
use your contact well no i was gonna
no i would i was going to uh
send it to myself and then send it to
send it to the contact
yeah and while you were finishing that
up
there were some memes that uh cam was
working on but then we moved on topics
before he was able to finish it so just
a quick recap we've got zach as the
highlander
that looks pretty good zach yeah um
good job cam oh the chain boy and the
alpha that's pretty good we did see this
one
uh here's me as the bad guy from
matt maxx pretty epic
here is a little fellowship of the ring
meme with our boy down here wait who is
he who is he filled in for
well he would be one balling him short
did you call him a hobbit at one point a
little hobbit i don't remember calling
him a hobbit
he is hobbing it looks like he belongs
in middle earth a little bit he's a
hobbit yeah
and finally um potential idea for uh
upgraded lovebot award a warrior bot
[ __ ] gundam america for sweden
love take that filter off your camera
you're not authorized hey you are not
hey you have not nope
remove that he's got the verified
tag remove that now he's refusing
isn't he he's a bot
i'm about to write an email get you
banned off instagram
um okay
all right so that's it eh
cool
have a great weekend it's friday baby
come on yeah [ __ ] yeah baby [ __ ] ya
[ __ ] ya baby [ __ ]
baby
i love that one
so we'll be back on monday with h3tv
we will be then back on thursday with
off the rails
friday after dark and then sunday if i
don't
[ __ ] you again
we'll be with the first ever episode
of our new show
no it'll be next week they've been
asking for hints but
god my tits look huge
look how fat i am i'm like
this is why i'm on this crazy diet but
like look at my tits brother they're
huge
look at this
and shout out to uh
shout out to the foot soldiers all the
foot soldiers especially our members and
especially uh paulie shore thanks for
watching a new friend
basically a crew member
except i actually like him i like how
he's a crew member he pays me
oh interesting yeah there's a different
dynamic i like that about paulie short
don't we folks
well guys and polly shore
thanks for watching we'll see you next
week yes
thanks for watching
you're listening to the hp podcast what
we got on the scene could it be poppa's
shoe nicer bill delfin talking front
wiper back wife what you gonna do with
me then you know and the whole damn crew
goose and gaps with all the guests
you'll see the best podcasts in the
world take it from me jc over j hp baby
we podcast now
you're watching h to the three green
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three